bonjour comment allez vous aujourd'hui
sauf pour une vidéo un peu spécial
guillaume de l'aîné de l'émission [ __ ]
allez je la refais comme un combat
bonjour guillaume a donc invité sur
l'énergie pour passer dix minutes dans
une émission dans laquelle il y aurait
justin bieber en gros justin va nous
poser des questions sur sa carrière ses
chansons et serra et celui qui répondra
le dernier entre guillaume et moi se
prendra une décharge électrique voilà
alors du coup vous en doutez qu'est ce
que je fais actuellement
bah je suis sur wikipédia voilà en train
de rôder ke le justin pedia je vais dans
ce challenge à guillaume je vais lui
dire guillaume si tu perds mon de scotch
les quatre trucs savage électrique on
avait fait avec mika on lit sculpturale
et quatre sur une main on est environ 3
des sharks
quitte à aller chez nrj etc et s'amuser
autant le film vu monter tout ça c'est
parti ouais
guillaume a pris un taxi moto bon voilà
c'est un canapé un bon bilan toujours
plus de style avec la charlotte yan télé
aussi avoir en plus j'ai un manteau à ma
taille je pourrais kraft échoue avec ça
ça me rend bien c'est un poncho et enfin
il est homme ça y est et la transmission
du monde
verizon dix mille jours devant qu'il
crie tchestine le bon brainstorming
d'ailleurs ils sont chauds ils sont tous
à pression sauf nous quand tu rentres
dans cet immeuble tué instantanément
stressé pour les stressés
oui férié les stress incroyable du coup
tu veux on fait le truc ou pas si je te
bats au quiz tu te prends une méga
décharge par montrer on va faire une
idée de une bonne idée de guillaume le
conseil sur le toit face à une foule de
gens ne voient ni même sur la
bourgeoisie et on va s'y faire presser
[ __ ] c'est pire qu'à la bibliothèque j
voici le déguisement et ça ça marchait
avec le bieber d'avant est ce que
quelqu'un en france quoi cette blague
mais c'est par la fenêtre
c'est juste y voilà ces gens ont crié on
les coulisses incroyable
pourquoi pas mais je commence à croire
mais c'est comme ans commence je regarde
toi redira vigiles après c'est à toi
les personnes à l'intérieur salut c'est
du cabinda
allez games est passé du coup j'ai j'ai
gratté ensuite voilà je serai européenne
et merde et maire du barp et est stressé
oui très bien
excusez moi monsieur net stressé oui non
pas du tout si vous êtes csn vous êtes
stressé
non ça va vous êtes stressé bois savent
apparemment va pas pouvoir filmer justin
tuck et déception après je peux me
déguiser et faire justin forsett fera
peut-être début aussi vers le studio
guillaume
on va lui demander s'il est stressé
excusez-moi déstresser non non bon ça va
péter pas stresser avec pour lancer la
pub faut juste faire ça voilà trente
minutes de pub avec lui on l'a pris
c'est moi monsieur vous êtes stressé
absolument pas mais vous transmets jeu
vidéo sur wii un miroir et où tous les
soirs sur nrj avec cet homme ça va au
monde son enfant j'ai pas le droit de
filmer quand justin va rentrer et on se
retrouve après
e
non en fait on ne fera pas l'interview
c'est le déplacement le plus inutile du
monde moi j'étais ma vidéo chez eux
depuis l'énergie en pls et devant le
building en train de chanter est une fan
de justin bieber qui a été évacué
puisque je sais pas elle était mal elle
m'a reconnu on venait la voir on va les
faire plein de gros bisous à training
raté ce n'est pas cette femme
ça va ça va tous les jours on met trop
bien ok et prenne fin pour apparemment
c'est gentil qu'on peut être pas comme
moi tout autour dans le studio
on va du coup faire le jeu mais sans
justin bieber pas que ça à faire 100
fois moins de vue peut-être que justin
l'avenir on peut voir cet homme sourire
de nouveau
voilà j'essaie télécommandes servent à
faire tu m'as envoyé un coup de jus je
suis pas un brassard cas sur le bras de
guillaume et il a la même chose pour le
brassard cas sur mon bras exquisite
bonjour ça va
migros est imparfaite alors tu as la
télécommande du mien j'ai la
télécommande du tien tu n'as tu pas ou
quoi non non non pas de lui même c'est
une bonne réponse allez jeter un coup
d'oeil ou pas mon prochain album
c'est le 13 novembre hier à 16 hockey
quel est mon signe astrologique une
europe et en asie
attends j'ai fait ou qui pétait en plus
avant mais c'était pas mal à mettre ces
débats qui fait qu'à tricorne rien de
poisson 2 quel est mon nom complet aux
mecs justin t shirt deux trous ça suffit
j'ai le droit de vérifier
ouais j'ai peur je me sens mal nazis ont
déconné le dominer le stress et le 1er
mars et l'année 94 et la dga 6 3 6 2
personnes iphoto s'est passé une
fourchette
et courtois c'était notre émission avec
justin bieber guillaume prennent en
photo avec lui je peux battre l'approché
hier vigiles la justin j'estime qu'avec
josacine ya la vie d'un vieux tube she
loves you say you say la fin de la
soirée chez energia guillaume c'est cool
tu voulais voir les vidéos de guillaume
n'hésitez pas à aller dans sa chaîne en
descriptions lui ces films avec des
caméras style et je passais en a ici on
entretient neymar garder une caméra
abuse des caméras comme ça voilà et moi
c'est des téléphones nul
bon voilà je voulais parler tu rigoles
hd offrant à bientôt iphone
bim bam au revoir avant le vent l'eau le
vent le vent non annoncé